thanks to incog for sponsoring today's
episode hello Internet welcome to film
Theory the show that's also having its
main character recast wubble love a
dubdub am I right oh oh sorry about that
had a Lee in my throat today we're
talking about Rick and Morty got to be
real with you and all the craziness that
was 2023 I almost missed that Rick and
Morty came back but now that I've gotten
a chance to sit down and actually binge
through the whole thing I got to admit
that these have got to be some of the
best episodes that the team has ever
delivered okay tough problem definitely
a spicy me the ball but but we can fix
it including some huge moments of
closure for these characters thank you
for visiting the fear hole Morty your
fear of relying on Rick has been
delicious we even wrap up some major
stories that previously probably would
have been milked for entire seasons why
threaten why not just do it because
using a weapon like this doesn't get you
left alone Morty think I want a bunch of
vengeful Summers coming after me
seriously though you don't come after me
it won't go well but you know me sure
the new Season's out we have some laughs
we shed some tears but now it's time to
do what we love to do at the end of
every season of Rick and Morty sit down
and analyze The Season's theme look at
this batch of episodes and try to figure
out what they were trying to tell us
what was the thesis of this year in case
you missed our season 6 Rick and Morty
theories we charted out that Rick was
clearly on an arc of healing of
confronting the grief that he felt over
losing his original wife and daughter
and trying to move forward with a new
found family what's more season 6
started to dabble with this idea of dis
satisfaction where we watch as everyone
who gets what they want are ultimately
left empty and unhappy realizing that
getting what you want sometimes isn't
exactly what you need season 7 though it
takes these themes and ratchets them up
to the next level we see the climax of
these character arcs about grief and
dissatisfaction and it shows us the
consequences of the two ways that you
can deal with grief through good healing
and bad healing and through these
stories I believe that we can actually
pinpoint who's going to be the next big
antagonist for Rick and Morty to face in
the coming Seasons That's Right loyal
theorists we are in the process of
witnessing ing the birth of the next big
Rick and Morty story arc and it shows us
who's going to be the big bad facing off
against the family from the very first
episode open up your portals friends
it's time to jump in now if you miss
season 7 of Rick and Morty I highly
recommend that you go and give it a
watch it provides some of the best
episodes of the series period but it
also gives us some of the most Rick and
Morty esque ideas ever to be put to
screen I'm talking about planets full of
people who turn to Spaghetti when they
die Rick and Jerry fusing together into
one super being generation long Wars
between letters and numbers front by ice
tea himself but on top of all the fun
adventure of the week Stories season 7
also brings together and wraps up some
of the show's longest running plot
threads the biggest ones being Rick
Prime and evil Morty after spending his
entire adult life hunting down the man
that killed his family the reason Rick
is the way that he is Rick and Morty
finally are able to confront Rick Prime
and with the help of evil Morty of all
people they wind up winning evil Morty
serves Rick Prime up hog tied on a
silver platter and then leaves and so of
course mind overtaken by rage Rick Goes
Ham killing Rick Prime with his bare
hands and a a splatter of spaghetti
sauce so brutal that it goes well beyond
the point of YouTube monetization at
first glance this seems like it should
be the big climax of the series I mean
the show's bringing in four of its
biggest players and letting them duke it
out ending in the death of what's
arguably Rick and Morty's main villain
but with the primary antagonist now off
the board the real villain of this
series can appear Rick's emptiness in
the wake of killing Rick Prime Rick
feels nothing he realizes that
completing this lifelong mission of
Vengeance hasn't really healed the part
of him that's been aching for years he
was given a motivation to track down
Rick Prime and kill him believing that
this would be the magical thing that
would help him feel better the magical
thing that could potentially bring Diane
back but now without that Target to
distract himself Rick has to sit there
with his pain knowing that he can never
really undo this loss this man the
smartest man in the Galaxy who can heal
any wound who has taken down Gods who
has brought himself back from the brink
of death now has to confront the one
thing that he can't fix the one thing
that he can't just science into
submission and what's worse is that Rick
Prime made sure to twist the knife on
his way out letting Rick know that he
used a powerful super weapon known as
the Omega device to erase Diane from the
entirety of the Multiverse no matter
where or when Rick goes he can never
ever get Diane back but perhaps the most
interesting thing about this episode was
its placement in the season it's episode
5 right in the middle you'd think that
this would be the sort of thing that
they would save as an epic climax to the
season but it's not because putting it
there would miss the point entirely the
battle that's the centerpiece of Rick
and Morty isn't against Rick prime it
was never against Rick Prime it's
against yourself it's about finding a
feeling for your own emotional scars the
death of Rick Prime in the middle of the
Season allows the back five episodes to
answer the really important question
then was any of this worth it sure Rick
got what he wanted Vengeance but did it
actually do anything to heal him clearly
not in a way that left him satisfied all
in all it was bad healing it's surface
level at best it leaves Rick arguably in
a worse place than when he first started
and it requires a now directionless Rick
to find new purpose and thankfully for
him he has all the necessary ingredients
for good healing right in front of him
his family and especially especially his
grandkids in the episode Rick fending
your Mort Morty checks in on a clearly
depressed Rick and does his best to make
him feel better by cashing in his Morty
Adventure cards encouraging Rick to take
him on another adventure just to get him
out of his Funk not right now Morty
definitely next week though you've been
saying that a while now buddy so I think
I'm going to give you a little nudge by
cashing in a few of these bad boys and
in the episode Whit quat am Moran summer
Rick admits that he respects summer
partially because her headstrong
personality reminds him of Diane I treat
you like an equal because I respect you
you remind me of your grandmother all of
this comes to a head in the season 7
finale fear no more probably one of the
top five episodes the show has ever
produced which sees Rick and Morty
discovering a mysterious fear hole in a
Denny's bathroom a hole with the ability
to manifest the greatest fears of anyone
that jumps inside though they initially
decide to leave it alone Morty rushes
back in and jumps down the hole with
Rick following after to save him they
both fight off monsters until they're
both able to escape from the hole later
when they arrive home Diane appears out
of a portal and Rick and Morty soon
realize that they're still stuck inside
the fear hole Rick thinks it's because
Morty's afraid of losing him to Diane
Morty thinks that his greatest fear is
watching Rick die intent to get them
both out of the fear hole Morty
continually faces his fears in an
attempt to overcome them but nothing
works until Rick mentions that Morty is
irreplaceable come on you're
irreplaceable Irreplaceable
Irreplaceable irre this makes Morty
realize that this Rick he isn't real
Rick never entered the hole after him
Mor's greatest fear is his overreliance
on Rick finally overcoming this true
fear Morty escapes the hole aw ing to
find Rick watching him from the outside
this entire experience is a massive step
forward for Morty but it also winds up
showing how far the positive healing has
been for Rick after Morty mentions that
he saw Diane inside the hole Rick runs
back to it and for a moment it looks
like he's going to jump in to try and
desperately hold on to Diane in any way
that he can just like we've seen him try
to do over and over and over again in
the series but then Rick stops instead
of jumping in the hole he takes out a
photo of Morty from his wallet tacks it
up onto the wall of Victors people who
escape from the hole it's an act of
pride in his grandson son this person
who represents Rick's future instead of
just always going back to his past Rick
is showing us that he's moved Beyond
just the empty bad healing that he'd
been pursuing this entire time and is
starting to work towards true good
healing deeper healing and that's not
the only thing that can help Rick heal
so can the sponsor of today's episode
incog I don't know if this has ever
happened to you but sometimes I'll be
doing some Google searches while
researching for a theory and then like
clockwork a day or two later I'm flooded
with ads about that exact same topic or
I'll sign up for a newsletter for a
store that I really like and then
suddenly get sent a bunch of spam emails
out of nowhere this sort of thing
happens because there are literally
thousands of companies out there whose
sole purpose is to collect your personal
data and then sell or trade that data
for their own profit that include your
full name your email and home address
even your phone and social security
number they might even have access to
your secret Sean sauce recipe thankfully
if you ask these data Brokers to delete
your information they legally have to do
it but the bad news is that it would
take an average person years of time to
do it by themselves time that you should
be using doing things that you actually
love to do like going on adventures
through time and space with your
favorite grandson and this is where
incog comes in see it's literally incog
job to do all that work for you with
your permission they can track down all
of these Brokers and make sure that your
data is off the market we've partnered
with incog in the past and let me tell
you the before and after of my email
inbox and text messages is huge actually
went back to take a look at how it was
going and they were still fighting for
me completing almost 120 removal
requests since late August that saved me
by their calculation literally 88 hours
of my time and it's also made a
noticeable difference in the amount of
spam that's clogging up my email
basically I haven't had to worry about
getting these weird newsletters or Shady
offers at all so if you want to protect
your personal data and keep your private
information private please go to incog
docomo I NC ni.com f l m t h e o r y or
you know save yourself the hassle and
just click the link in the description
because it is so much easier that way
you can get a great deal on their great
service thanks again to incog for
sponsoring today's video now let's jump
back into the Multiverse of Rick and
Morty for the first half of the season
the show really focuses on the concept
of bad healing touching more characters
than just Rick for example in the
episode Air Force Wong we see how
president Curtis responds to a breakup
by hijacking a hive mind hoping to see
his approval ratings hit 100% cuz if he
can't have the approval of the woman he
loves well the rest of the United States
will have to do good president president
good good good I get it now wow what a
president approval here president
approved this is the perfect example of
trying to use external approval as a
method for healing something that ends
up hurting both the person trying to
heal as well as everyone around him
similarly in the season premiere how
poopy got his poop back we see how Mr
Poopy butthole is dealing with the
divorce and uh let's say it's not going
too well I agree Beth I'm a piece of
garbage instead of letting go of his
ex-wife moving on and creating a healthy
new direction for his life to go in to
support his son Mr Poopy butthole goes
on a bender with Rick and Hugh Jackman
ending up kidnapping poor poopy Jr the
way he's trying to quote unquote heal
here is by holding on to everything that
he lost to the point that it ends up
hurting the people that he cares about
the most sound familiar well it should
it's what Rick's been doing to the Smith
family for the past six seasons and as
you'd expect this sort of selfish coping
ultimately doesn't turn out all that
well for poopy yes you didn't see season
4 episode 3 let's go this is exactly
what Rick would have done earlier in the
series Mr Poopy butth hole is what Rick
could have become but he doesn't because
of his family and all the good healing
that happens after he kills Rick Prime
you want some proof all you have to do
is look into the back half of season 7's
episodes and you get your answer for
example both those episodes I mentioned
earlier where Rick leans on Morty and
summer to positively heal they come
after he kills Rick Prime in Rise of the
numeric cons we see the alphabet trian
and Americans heal a rift between their
people that's lasted for Generations all
because two of them realized that they
weren't all that different with the help
of Rick I think when we started getting
it on that amulet showed us the truth of
our Origins father in Mort Ragnarok Rick
starts the episode trying to take
advantage of Bigfoot to gain power
enough so that Bigfoot literally wants
to kill Rick over and over but by the
end of it all he finds common ground
with Bigfoot and the two part ways on
good terms why are we at the woods time
to go on home big fella oh uh okay
you're free and of course the fear hole
represents the end of that growth Arc
but my favorite example that I want to
call attention to actually comes from
the episode right before Rick kills Rick
Prime and it we see a miniature version
of this entire Arc that Rick's on in the
season standout episode that's am morti
we see a planet where those who choose
to end their own life have their
internal organs turned to Spaghetti yep
that is really the plot and trust me
they somehow find a way to make it work
why how their cortisol increases the
starch content in their bloodstream
changing their intestines into one long
spaghetti noodle but the most messed up
part of this whole thing is that the
spaghetti is delicious and everybody
wants to eat it despite realizing where
it came from who's ready for more
ethical spagetti those are so good has
the parmesian this ends up turning into
big business for the planet who then
encourage more and more people to cut
their lives short all for their own
profit truly it is a messed up idea but
it's a brilliant commentary on how
sometimes we can only see people as
numbers a source for Content feeding on
their misery and self-destruction
literally finding their pain delicious
so we continue to inflict it and feed
off of it so then where does the healing
come in well at the end of the episode
Rick and Morty broadcast the entire life
of an old man showing his pain but also
his UPS his Downs his loves his
heartbreak his humanity and afterwards
no one can stomach the SP anymore they
suddenly see the people on this planet
as more than just content they see the
beauty of the humanity in this situation
how relatable it all is and suddenly
everyone is able to heal as for Rick
it's the seed that's the beginning of
his choice to move forward in a healthy
way one that becomes all the more
powerful given how far he's come so
that's everything that happened the
season but obviously it wouldn't be a
Rick and Morty theory if we didn't also
try to figure out where things are
headed to next and I believe that it all
comes down to this little guy I don't
believe it's any coincidence that this
season was bookended by Mr Poopy
butthole in fact these episodes show
just how far in the opposite direction
he's growing from Rick and the Smiths
not only did we see him try to kidnap
his own child as I talked about before
but in the Stinger of the last episode
Mr Poopy butthole follows the darkest of
paths killing and replacing a separate
Mr Poopy butthole From Another Universe
to replace him to live his happy life
with his happy family sounds a lot like
something Rick used to do huh finding a
new universe to start over in when
everything falls apart in his life
resetting things back to a status quo so
he never has to grow never has to face
his own pain what's more the series is
going to need it a new antagonistic
Force now that Rick Prime is dead and
evil Morty is off the table remember
when I stole my kid I stole one of these
too it's all about having a goal and
stopping in nothing to achieve it that
is the role Mr Poopy butthole is going
to be taking here in a similar way to
how Rick Prime was the rickest Rick the
person that most embodied the worst of
Rick's traits earlier in his life Mr
Poopy butthole is going to become the
healed Rick's opposite someone who's
felt a lot of the same pain but goes
about healing from it in the worst ways
possible hurting everyone around him
he'll embody all the bad healing that
Rick himself used to embrace in the end
Rick's ultimate test isn't his own
healing but whether he's able to teach
others his best friends how to heal but
hey that's just a theory a film Theory
and
[Music]
cut
n